OWN GENDER, BUT FIRST, THE WAR
AGAINST MEN.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
THE SERIOUS TOXICS -- TOXIC --
TOXIC MASCULINITY, BUT NOW THATM
TOXIC MASCULINITY, BUT NOW THATN
TOXIC MASCULINITY, BUT NOW THAT-
TOXIC MASCULINITY, BUT NOW THATE
TOXIC MASCULINITY, BUT NOW THATT
TOXIC MASCULINITY, BUT NOW THATH
TOXIC MASCULINITY, BUT NOW THATS
INFECTED ALMOST EVERY AREA OF
THE CULTURE, THE BUSINESSES,
SCHOOLS, AND OUTCOME OF COURSE
OUR POLITICS.
WELL, DID DISMISSING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF MEN THROUGHOUT
THE HISTORY HAS BECOME OH, SO
INSPIRING.
OR AT LEAST COME
ELIZABETH WARREN THINK SO.
>> I WOULD HAVE WANTED GIVE THIS
SPEECH RIGHT HERE, AND NOT
BECAUSE OF THE ARCH BEHIND ME OR
THE PROTESTANT THAT THIS SQUARE
IS NAMED FOR, NO, WE ARE NOT SUR
IS NAMED FOR, NO, WE ARE NOT SUE
TODAY BECAUSE OF FAMOUS
FORTUNES OR FAMOUS MEN.
IN FACT, WE ARE NOT HERE FOR MAN
AT ALL.
WE ARE HERE BECAUSE OF SOME
HARDWORKING WOMEN.
>> Laura: WELCOME HER COMMENTS
KIND OF TOSSING OFF INVOLVEMENT
OF MEN IN SOCIETY, IT SPEAKS
VOLUMES ABOUT THE DIRECTION THE
DEMOCRATS WILL TAKE IF THEY GAIN
CONTROL AGAIN.
SO MEN WHO ARE HETEROSEXUAL
STRONG, AGGRESSIVE COMPETITORS,
ARE NO LONGER AN ACCEPTABLE PART
OF SOCIETY, NOT REALLY.
THEY ARE THE PROBLEM.
AFTER ALL, THE PROFESSIONALS
HAVE TOLD US SO.
LAST YEAR, THE AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION
RELEASED GUIDELINES FOR PRACTICE
WITH BOYS AND MEN.
THAT TRASH
MASCULINITY AS LEADING TO
AGGRESSION AND VIOLENCE AS AN
ANSWER TO ALL INTERPERSONAL
CONFLICT AS WELL AS SUBSTANCE
ABUSE, INCARCERATION AND EARLY
MORTALITY.
WELL, OF COURSE FOR YEARS
HOLLYWOOD HAS BEEN PUSHING THE
CROP TOP PAJAMA BOY VERSION OF
MASCULINITY ON US AND WE HAVE
GOTTEN USED TO IT.
NOW EVEN TIME MAIL BRANDS AND
BUSINESSES ARE TRYING TO MAKE
MAN FEEL GUILTY ABOUT BEING MEN.
>> THE ME TOO MOVEMENT.
>> MASCULINITY.
IS THIS THE BEST A MAN CAN GET?
♪ ♪
IS IT?
WE CAN'T HIDE FROM IT.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR TOO LONG.
WE CAN'T LAUGH IT OFF.
>> BOYS WILL BE BOYS.
>> Laura: WELL, NOT ALL BOYS
WILL BE BOYS BUT YOU ALMOST
THINK SO AFTER WATCHING ADS LIKE
THAT.
IT USED TO BE ONLY THE FRINGE E
OF THE GRANTEE FEMINISTS BELIEVE
THE TRADITIONAL FAMILY
STRUCTURES WERE INHERENTLY
OPPRESSIVE AND DANGEROUS.
OF COURSE WITH MAN HEAD OF THE
HOUSEHOLD IN SOME CASES BEING
THE MAIN CULPRITS.
BUT NOW THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS CAPTIVE TO
THIS ANTIMALE OUTLOOK.
IF YOU WERE A YOUNG MAN WHO GREW
UP PREWOKE NOSE, IF YOU ARE A
MEMBER OF ALL MALE CLUB OR
FRATERNITY, OR IF YOU PLAYED
A SPORT ESPECIALLY ONE LIKE I
DON'T KNOW FOOTBALL OR LACROSSE,
YOU ARE IMMEDIATELY SUSPECT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW WELL YOU
LIVED YOUR PERSONAL LIFE OR HOW
MUCH YOU ACHIEVED IN YOUR
PROFESSIONAL LIFE.
YOU ARE VERY EXISTENCE IS A
THREAT TO THIS NEW ORDER.
NOW, WE ALL JUST SAW WHAT THE
LEFT IT AGAIN OR TRIED TO AND
THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
BUT PEOPLE LIVING IN WASHINGTON
KNOW WHAT THE CULTURE WAS
LIKE AND AT LEAST THEN.
>> THE MEMORIES, THEY WILL BE
TESTIFYING TO HER MEMORIES
RECORDED IN THE BRAINS OF DRUNK
TEENAGE BOYS.
>> HE WAS DRUNK ALLEGEDLY IN ONE
OF THESE INCIDENTS.
THE FRONT -- YES, THERE MAY BE
QUESTIONS OF CANDOR.
>> I THINK FRAT BOY IS ON TRIAL
HERE.
>> Laura: BUT DEFAMING
KAVANAUGH, OF COURSE AS A
PREDATOR, THAT WAS ANOTHER WAY
OF CLAIMING TRUMP WAS ONE.
WHICH DEMOCRATS WILL THINK WILL
HELP THEM WITH WOMEN VOTERS.
THEY SAY THEY CAN RIDE THE MEAD
TO WAVE RIGHT INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
BUT THEY HAVE TO THINK WOMEN ARE
VERY, VERY STUPID AND IF YOU ARE
A MALE DEMOCRAT POLITICIAN, YOU
ARE FORCED TO REPEAT -- REFER TO
THE GENDER FOR YEARS AND
APOLOGIZE YOUR SEX.
>> I THINK WE WOULD LOOK FOR
SOMEBODY WHO IS MAYBE NOT OF THE
SAME GENDER THAT I AM.
AND MAYBE SOMEBODY MIGHT BE A
COUPLE OF YEARS YOUNGER THAN ME.
>> I WILL HAVE A WOMAN RUNNING
MATE.
IT IS CLEAR FOR ME TO DO THAT.
IT WOULD BE DIFFICULT NOT TO
SELECT A WOMAN WITH SO MANY
EXTRAORDINARY WOMEN RUNNING
RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: OKAY.
WOW, MAYBE A WOMAN WOULD BE THE
BEST PERSON TO PICK OUT OF BASIS
OF MERIT, BUT WHEN DOES ORGANS
ALONE BE A QUALIFICATION FOR
HIGH OFFICE, STUNNING.
WHICH LED ME TO WONDER, CAN
PRINCESS FITTING BOWL OR
KAMALA HARRIS PICK A MALE
RUNNING MATE?
OR WILL THAT MAKE THEM PART OF
THE PATRIOT -- PATRIARCH AS
WELL.
AUNT MSNBC JOY REID TOOK THE
ANTIMALE NARRATIVE A STEP
FURTHER ADDING RACIAL AND
RELIGIOUS ELEMENTS TO IT.
I MEAN YOU HAVE A VERY
DETERMINED MINORITY AND IN THIS
CASE WEALTHY, WHITE MAN WEALTHY
WHITE CHRISTIAN MEN AND
CHRISTIAN AMERICANS WHO ARE OF
THE FUNDAMENTAL VARIETY WHO ARE
VERY CLEAR THAT NO MATTER
WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY HAVE TO
PULL THE SOUTH AFRICA MODEL TO
MAINTAIN MODEL FOREVER, THEY
WILL DO IT.
THEY ARE NOT AFRAID OF IT AND
EXCUSE ME, OPEN ABOUT IT.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE AVATAR FOR
THIS.
>> Laura: THEY ARE
INCREASINGLY OPEN ABOUT IT.
I MUST HAVE MISSED ALL OF THAT,
AND BY THE WAY, I HAVE TO SAY
THIS "WHEN THEY DISMISS OUR
FOUNDERS, THIS IS WHERE THEY ARE
GOING.
THE ENTIRE AMERICAN EXPERIMENT,
THEY BELIEVE WAS SINFUL AND
AWFUL BECAUSE IT WAS STARTED BY
CONQUEST.
WHITE MEN WITH THEIR TRADITIONAL
NOTIONS OF WORK AND MORALITY,
SUBJUGATED WOMEN AND OTHER
MINORITIES, END OF STORY,
NOTHING REALLY GOOD CAME AFTER
THAT.
THAT'S THE THINKING GOES, IT IS
THE DUTY OF ALL SECULAR LEFT IS
TO MARGINALIZE AND HOBBLE MEN
WHO OBSTRUCT THEIR VISION OF
REVOLUTIONARY CHANGE, POLITICAL
AND OTHERWISE.
NOW THINK OF WHERE THAT LEAVES
US AS A SOCIETY.
THE ENTIRE MIND-SET IN THE
COUNTRY.
THERE ARE MEN EITHER NEUTERED OR
PERPETUALLY IN A DEFENSIVE
POSTURE DISMISSIVE OR ANGRY.
AND ALIENATED.
NOW, THAT IS TOXIC.